you're washing swype we're in the Land
of Fire and Ice for a festive special
coming up on the show Angela explores
iceland's volcanoes with the latest
technology that could help predict an
eruption
I find out how the country's powerful
natural energy could boost its tech
status and we journey to Iceland's
capital to meet one of Europe's most
successful video games developers
welcome to Iceland an island famous for
its cold weather and stunning natural
beauty so what's a tech show like us
doing here well in this bumper episode
of swype are we showing you how this
Nordic country is embracing technology
to make the most of what nature gave it
but at this time of year we've only got
a few hours of daylight so we better get
on with this show first up angela has
been checking out volcanoes of course
this might look peaceful but beneath the
glacier is one of Iceland's most active
and dangerous volcanoes Katla is being
closely watched by scientists who say it
has the potential to be more damaging
than this one which brought Europe to a
standstill in 2010
we went to Katla to see how technology
is helping researchers predict the next
big eruption drones like this one allow
scientists to monitor seismic activity
by capturing footage and collecting data
in areas that are difficult to reach
there are several uses for these Jones
to help the scientists one would be to
use the aerial images we take to create
a detailed three-dimensional map of the
area another would be to put sensors on
those Jones on or use infrared cameras
to monitor the thermal activities of an
area a DJI drone was also used to film
within 200 feet of iceland's bada bunker
volcano where the lava reach
temperatures of almost 2,000 degrees it
captured a close-up glimpse of nature at
its most dramatic I'm standing in the
crater on the glacier covering Katla the
volcano normally has a major eruption
about twice every 100 years the last
time it broke through the ice was in
1918 and his cause devastating glacial
flooding and scientists say
statistically this volcano is over do
another eruption as well as using drones
to keep an eye on the Earth's movement
scientists are also using advanced
sensors and GPS tracking to see whether
magma is accumulating
a team from the University of Iceland
regularly check on the monitoring
stations set up across the most active
regions of the country where data is
gathered and fed back in real-time the
technology we used to try to foresee
volcanic eruptions includes seismometers
to pick up small earthquakes as magma is
moving it includes geodetic stations to
measure the ground movements in the
terms of of millimeters or centimeters
of expansion and it includes sensors to
detect volcanic gas it is difficult to
predict when the next eruption might
start and whether previous eruptions can
be used as a guide as to what might
happen next but technology like this
could save lives by helping scientists
get to know Iceland's volcanic systems
more closely Angela Barnes Sky News stay
with us we've got a lot of exciting
things coming up on this swype festive
special throughout the show will be
looking at who's had a good year in the
world of tech and who's had a year to
forget plus I go inside one of the
world's most extreme data centers and
find out what the cloud really looks
like different countries have different
traditions at this time of year here in
Iceland they don't just have one father
Christmas figure they've got 13 they're
called Yule Lads the children here put a
shoe on their bedroom window every night
for 13 days in the run-up to Christmas
so that the Yule Lads can leave them
presents nice ones if they've been
well-behaved so we are skies very own
little you lad well technology
correspondent actually if he would talk
us through some of his top toys for this
festive season and beyond here's Tom
well yes Merry Christmas and all that
mmm that's better on to the gadgets
first up is this nerf gun it's a modulus
gun which means you can put all sorts of
things to your heart's content
customizing it with things like this
stock
this scope but crucially it does the
important thing that a nerf gun should
do and it fires lots of bullets
wonderful if you're slightly less
destructive may be more creative this is
a DIY gamer kit from technology will
save us it's a great way to learn how to
build your own games console you have to
work out how to put components like this
together now the last few years have all
been about drones and look here's
another one it's the small parrot drone
but the twist is that this drone can
when it's combined with this boat here
go on water and work as a remote control
this is a fan and that's how it
cools along finally transportation
hoverboards are already a massive cliche
and sometimes they explode so why not
try a pair of rocket skates they don't
actually have Rockets in them instead
press the buttons on the back and you'll
activate the electric motors and then
it's just a case of gliding gracefully
to your destination Oh bless didn't Tom
look great in that hat now remember this
stay with us to see our take on 2015's
tech ups and downs data it's never
really been a sexy subject has it but as
our digital connectivity increases
companies are looking for more places to
keep it well here in Iceland they're
capitalizing on the natural resources to
tap into that need I got to go inside
one of the world's most extreme data
centers and I finally discovered what
the cloud looks like Iceland a land of
breathtaking views rumbling volcano
spouting geezers and Viking history but
now it's also home to these data centers
that's right inside these ugly
warehouses are massive hard drives
powering the types of Internet
applications we use on our computers and
phones every day so far it has three
when we talk about using that
cloud we imagined this thing floating
above us but actually go inside this
converted NATO base and you see what the
cloud really looks like companies from
all over the world rent this space huge
computers with billions of calculations
taking place every second but servers
need to be kept cool which can get very
pricey and that gives chilly Iceland and
advantage over warmer countries these
openings on the wall allow fresh cool
ambient air to come into our data center
and into our computers the netting that
you see here prevents the snow from
coming in and we can do this in Iceland
pre-cooling all year long along with
cold weather Iceland also happens to be
blessed with heat and water in abundance
almost a hundred percent of its
electricity comes from renewable sources
this is the famous blue lagoon it's
lovely and warm that has spread by water
that is naturally deep underground that
geothermal energy along with
hydroelectric power means Iceland can
drive its data centers in a very
eco-friendly way
but the country still needs a boost from
some big Silicon Valley names who have
so far opted to put their data in other
Nordic countries Facebook has one in
Sweden google in finland while apple is
putting one in Denmark hey Chris Urkel
nevertheless at the University of
Iceland staff working alongside the next
generation of tech experts are
optimistic the data center industry here
in Iceland is very young and I think
it's just a matter of time when large
companies realize the benefits of
storing data here because of the low
energy prices and the renewable energy
others safe attacks biggest names to
bring their data here they'll want more
than pretty landscapes and cheap
electricity they need peace of mind
about connectivity we have three cables
that connect Iceland to the Internet I
think we need a lot more than three and
when you have a lot more cables
connecting to Iceland I think they feel
a lot more comfortable that they know
that if one cable goes down they can
piggyback on others the end of the year
is a good time for reflection so we've
nominated our picks of the tech products
brands and personalities that could call
2015 a pretty successful year but we've
also considered those who might not look
back on the gear with such fond memories
here's stew with part one of our tech
ups and downs of 2015
our first up of the year goes to Mark
Zuckerberg who's had a pretty
significant 2015 the facebook founder
and his wife Priscilla Chan had their
first child daughter max in December and
as the couple told the world about her
birth Zukerberg announced he will be
giving away 99% of his facebook shares
at the time worth 45 billion dollars
that's 30 billion pounds he and
Priscilla will be giving their wealth to
causes that help the planet a big
Christmas pantomime style boo this year
for an app called people the idea was
let you publicly rate other humans like
he would give scores to hotels or
restaurants online this received a lot
of strong criticism resulting in the
inventors making big concessions
including making the app and opt-in
service it's been a great year for two
kinds of emerging technology in
particular augmented reality and virtual
reality or VR have been some of the buzz
words of 2015 but you can expect to see
much more of this kind of tech in 2016
and beyond HTC vive VR device is due out
in April and will compete with oculus
rift and PlayStation VR which could be
released early in the year augmented
reality could revolutionize industries
like design and medicine allowing you to
overlay virtual images onto the real
world microsoft hololens is in
development although there isn't a
general release date yet we've got
plenty more coming up stay with us
we're going inside one of Iceland's
best-known Game Studios for a go on one
of its new releases and while we're at
it we'll be looking back at the year in
games welcome back to us white festive
special from a very chilly but
spectacular Iceland it's currently
minus-7 degrees Celsius and we've
arrived to record snowfall still to come
on the show we get nostalgic with a look
back at the swype teams 2015 highlights
but first here's part two of our tech
ups and downs from the past 12 months
2015 has undoubtedly been a good year
for space travel and exploration in
September Nasser announced they'd found
strong evidence of water on Mars and
then there's Tim Peake the British
astronaut who has blasted off into space
for a six-month mission on the
International Space Station it hasn't
been a perfect dear for Apple more on
that later but there have been positives
for one of the biggest names in tech the
Apple watch was released in April and
while it hasn't caught on in the same
way as the iphone yet it's received wide
critical acclaim winning awards from t3
pocket-lint and stuff magazine apple
will also be pleased with its smartphone
sales the iphone 6s and 6s plus broke
company sales records with 13 million
handsets being sold in the first three
days release in September Samsung will
be pleased with the year that seen it
beat Apple to several awards for its
smartphones t3 pocket-lint and stuff
magazine all named the galaxy s6 edge
phone of the year their annual award
ceremonies the curve phone has been
praised for its design and features
which have seen it get one over on the
latest iPhone release
they've already made an appearance on
our list with an up entry but 2015
hasn't all been positive for Apple the
biggest down for them was when Taylor
Swift refused to put her album 1989 on
new streaming service Apple music that
was because the company said it wouldn't
pay royalties to artists during a three
month free trial Apple changed its mind
on the policy the next day and last and
definitely least our final entry is a
downer for hoverboards several airlines
ban them because of potential fire
dangers and national Trading Standards
in the UK confiscated 15,000 of them
over the same concerns there have been
doubts about whether it's even legal to
ride them on the pavement or on the
roads in England Wales and Scotland and
perhaps most importantly of all they
don't actually have them now we've come
inside one of iceland's best known video
games developers CCP games and if you've
ever heard of the popular sci-fi title
EVE Online come and meet is executive
producer and eat for anyone who doesn't
know just tell us a little bit about eve
online so Eavis this online sense
fiction gaming universe that has
actually been live since 2003 and it has
this really great community from all
over the world who fly spaceships there
and fight you trade and tell their own
stories so what are you working on now
well as EP we've really jumped into
virtual reality like I see some headsets
here yeah I have a game here that our
studio in Shanghai is working on
actually it's called Eve gun Jack and
we're gonna have a go because you've got
it's past our track seven year so what's
the aim of this game so you're operating
a huge gun turret and a mining ship so
you have to protect the mining operation
from you know pirates and all kinds of
spaceships are attacking
kill them
how long does it take to design develop
a game like this well it's kind of like
normal game development it takes a team
you know several months to get going and
then you refine a Polish until you're
really happy with it and how long until
you see a time when nearly everybody has
a virtual reality headset in their homes
oh I really hope that a lot of people
get these ones for Christmas you can get
ahold of these right now and the game
we're playing is also available right
now but I think next year is going to be
a big year for virtual reality 2015 has
been an interesting year for gaming
we've had titles brought back from the
dead to consoles breaking records here's
Chris with a roundup in the year that
III turned 20 we saw a lot of big gaming
announcements Square Enix surprised
everyone by revealing the 90s classic
final fantasy 7 would be getting a
next-gen remake it something fans had
been calling for for more than a decade
but few expected it would ever really
happen meanwhile Sony said it's missing
in action title The Last Guardian would
be coming out after all there was big
news from EA who announced the fourth
entry in the Mass Effect franchise and
microsoft revealed that xbox 360 games
would now work on xbox one something
much demanded by fans so those were the
big announcements of 2015 but what about
the games releases let the legend come
back to life metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain came out to wide critical
acclaim it made 179 million dollars on
its launch day star wars battlefront was
released ahead of the latest film in the
sci-fi saga and it became the
fastest-selling game based on the
franchise while the much-anticipated
fallout 4 shipped 12 million copies in
just 24 hours but it was the witcher 3
that scooped the year's biggest
accolades the open-world RPG claimed
five awards at the golden joysticks
including game of the year and it was
another year another fifa this
installment saw the inclusion of female
players for the first time also flying
the flag for women in gaming was Lara
Croft the iconic Explorer was
back for the second installment in the
revamped Tomb Raider franchise and there
was a return for everybody's favorite
Italian plumber super mario turned 30
and Nintendo celebrated the big occasion
by releasing Super Mario maker there was
also some sad news from the Japanese
games maker the company's president and
CEO Satoru Iwata passed away at 55 2015
was a year of milestones in the gaming
world Sony's ps4 was the company's
fastest selling console ever and YouTube
gamer PewDiePie became the owner of the
first channel to hit 10 billion views so
it was a busy 2015 but what will next
year hold many are predicting it could
be time for virtual reality to take off
so 2016 could be just as eventful Chris
Cregan Sky News we can honestly say
filming this episode of swype here in
Iceland has been one of the highlights
of the year for us I say one off because
the swype team have done a lot in 2015
here's a little reminder of some of our
tech adventures technology is
transforming the skiing and boarding
experience well like more layers of
intensity to this music so we've added a
synth synth line there
what character are you turning me into
you today I'll turn you into the butt
aha get out that's amazing do i do I
look realistic well you definitely
realistic by then if you cut the pot
this technology currently being trialed
plugs punters into a digital casino and
gives them the chance to win or lose
real money this building is a one-off
using just solar power it's able to
create enough electricity to keep it
running all year round now we're over
has a go flying over mountain what we're
about to do increase my speed very good
some of the rooms are linked up by
radios and CCTV so you can see what's
happening to other audience members
making it feel a bit like you're inside
a video game this would be my view if I
was the camera ball Hey look at that
there I am that there you are making a
big budget video game takes a lot of
work although it might look like play
the people at TT games have a dedication
to lego do they have names yeah the one
on the left's called p 10 on the on the
Rights called n1c which is short for bio
and nicks are Bionic so this is a cycle
superhighway 3 and
to get caught on some very special
cameras what we've done the first time
ever is install some thermal imaging
cameras up here to detect cyclists
assume that anything that you put into
digital format is vulnerable ah even if
it's a text or what's that message yeah
i mean just assume telematics is the
real theme of the show this year this
unit is being put into every Porsche at
the factory level from the get-go here's
a demo a state-of-the-art sensor
technology taking sports to new heights
these cables stretch out for over 900
miles around these tunnels and just like
any other connection if something goes
wrong they need to be fixed but for that
to happen somebody's sitting thousands
of miles away needs to plug it up if
sights and sounds just aren't enough for
you when you head to the cinema how
about this it's called 4dx seats that
move around air water and fog effects or
synchronized to the action on screen was
a few major events on the gaming
calendar III couple months ago in June
is where all the big games are announced
but games call me here in Cologne in
Germany's were 250,000 people get to
play those games for the first time and
myself as a journalist I get to play a
lot of these games for the first time we
put these all together and a piece of
software called out yourself and that
combines them into a 3d model well I
might not look as agile as the
footballer but it's good enough to help
design my 3d printed movie costume if I
ever needed one well we did set gets
dark quickly here and now it has also
got a lot older it's about minus 10 here
and the outskirts of Reykjavik thank you
for joining us for this is very festive
swype we'll see you again soon blessed
that's Icelandic so goodbye
you